hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again we
have some actual year four news I am not
playing with you right now you saw the
title you saw the thumbnail I am so
[ __ ] excited right now let's get into
it it is year for the year of reckoning
so as always like to be if you do
injustice cry before new and let's get
started with today's video as always
this stuff will be in the description
down below or even in the comments
possibly if I posted there if you guys
want to look at this stuff for yourself
right from the source but it says here
for honor year for the year of reckoning
hey warriors we know that you have been
patiently waiting to know what's going
on in next year in for honor and we are
excited to announce today what we have
planned for year for the year of
reckoning from launched three years ago
to for honor today we're incredibly
proud on the progress the game has made
none of which would have been possible
without the unique relationship we built
with you our players year 4 is about
learning and building upon what we have
experienced together in the past three
years so let's keep the party going
we'll be able to share more details in
January 2020 but here's an overview of
what's in store and it says the year of
reckoning is a turning point in for
honors history the great war that has
been raging over the past years takes an
unexpected turn the earth has quieted
down but new leaders arise in warriors
across all factions they decide what
they're really fighting for for for
there's going to be four unique seasons
and two new heroes coming to this season
what saw I'm assuming there's going to
be two new heroes for two of the seasons
and then in the other two seasons we
might get a handful of rebirth and maybe
some other changes like back in year 2
it says like you're three in year four
we will have four new seasons each with
its own theme rewards and activities two
new faces will rise during the year of
reckoning one hero will be released
during year for season two and the other
in year four season four their arrival
will coincide with the storyline as well
of the events of the year and its
seasons and we can't wait to find out
which side you choose on top of that of
course you will be able to purchase
these characters upon release and unlock
new characters would steal as usual on
top of that with year four season 1 we
will be introducing a new reward system
the four honor battle pass and the past
rewards relied solely upon random drops
after matches and scavenger crates which
gave little visibility on the items you
variable to unlock now we be able to
clear throughout a hundred tears within
the battle pass where you will be able
to unlock
items throughout gameplay the Battle
Pass will be limited to character
customization items and consumables mean
that you do not need to purchase this to
have accessed it to the two heroes
coming during the year
before on our battle path will consist
of a free and a premium pass with a
shared progression across the different
tiers and resetting with each new season
everyone will have access to the free
pass in its rewards in the free pass you
can unlock items such as ornaments steel
color swatches champion status embossing
x' and more while premium pass owners
can unlock customization rewards such as
signatures new weapons new effects new
executions and tons more both free and
premium passes will have rewards for all
heroes it is also important for us to
make the premium pass in addition and
not a substitute for the existing means
of getting content in the game thus far
thus we will be keeping original options
for players with the new content of the
week sales scavenger crates etc drops at
the end of matches to go with
customization items this is just a
little bit more to add to the game
though they said they're gonna have more
details but year for season one battle
pass in January 2020 what the [ __ ] we're
getting a battle piss on top of that
they're gonna be changing the fight core
experience with 26 characters in the
current roster and two new faces joining
in year four bouncing remains a top
priority for us this includes hero
balancing of course but also game-mode
balancing a major step towards
strengthening our process of balancing
has been the introduction of testing
grounds for year 4 we can expect this
tool to have a big role and how the dev
team continues to bring changes to the
game the focus of year remains on
increasing character viability allowing
for a wider range in team composition at
a higher level of play and continue to
improve offense to enhance the core
gameplay of foreigner on a more general
level this is a whole lot of gibberish
but I know it obviously means a hell of
a lot of ton because you know this is
the exact Couric's this is the art of
combat system like this is the the
fighting that we've been using for
almost four years now so they're gonna
have probably a hell of a lot more
details come 2020 this they're just
saying that they're gonna be updating
this maybe changing a few things the
competitive scene is extremely important
to us as it is to you it helps the
community grow and ultimately a compass
in shaping the experience of the game
the competitive scene is a pillar which
we intend to expand in year 4 with an
all new access competitive program set
to launch of course more details soon
and as well we will expand on
all elements in January as we get closer
to the launch of the year of reckoning
we are really excited for what the year
has to come lastly we want to thank you
for all the creativity that you guys
have shown us over the past three years
worth it because play fanfiction videos
memes fan are everything like that that
we felt inspired to include for year
four and also they wanted to add and
then the very last thing they say is oh
and one last thing
new armors are coming this year meaning
we will be getting new armor before the
end of this year so probably during the
new event maybe right at the very end
but yes new armor will finally be coming
none of this soon [ __ ] that we've
been expecting but guys this is a huge
amount of stuff to go over
we have a whole new year confirmed with
two new characters for new seasons a
battle pass as well as a update on the
four quarks the fighting core experience
the competitive mode and a bunch of
other things and the new armor is
confirmed to come this year let me know
what you guys think about this stuff in
the comments below I'm super excited for
all this but yeah guys with that that's
going to be the end of the vaisya
hopefully you guys did enjoy it like the
V if he did subscriber free nukes I'm
gonna be covering everything that has to
do with for honor in the up and coming
year of year four with this battle pass
all the rewards and everything like that
and the comments down below let me know
anything and any of your thoughts
whether it be positive or negative and I
guys take care I have a greater day and
peace out
you